the xbox series x's one terabyte
internal ssd is really fast
and can load up some games in a matter
of seconds but with 802 gigabytes
actually free to use you can fill it up
quickly with the size of games today
and don't forget the series s only comes
with a 512 gigabyte drive
so what are some solutions for expanding
your storage and how well do they
perform
in comparison i've got some answers for
you i covered this topic a bit in my
full comprehensive xbox series x preview
but i think this is important to
highlight on its own
and i have a few new details this time
around here look the three drives i've
used
the one terabyte seagate ssd expansion
card
a samsung t5 external ssd and a western
digital passport
external hard drive i'll start with the
one terabyte expansion card built
specifically for the series x and series
s this is the drive that plugs directly
into the console you just insert it and
it's immediately ready to use
it interfaces with the xbox hardware and
takes full advantage of that velocity
architecture microsoft has been flexing
in terms of speeds it's technically the
best solution and works identically to
the internal ssd
there's virtually no difference in load
times in the games we tested
however it carries a hefty price tag at
220 bucks
before we get into usb drives an
important thing to note is that they
cannot play series x or s
specific games off of the drive that's
where this expansion card comes in
clutch
especially once we start seeing more
series x and s only games
usb external drives can store those
games but they would have to be
transferred to the internal
drive or expansion card in order to be
played at least transfer speeds are fast
all things considered
these conditions can also apply to
certain xbox one games that have
received series x optimizations
as was the case for me with gears 5 and
gears tactics
otherwise you can play xbox one and
previous gen backwards compatible games
straight off a usb drive using a usb 3.0
cable and they'll still use the quick
resume game swapping feature without a
hitch
so onto an external ssd as i mentioned
earlier i used the samsung t5
with the usb c to usb 3.1 cable
and in terms of moving data around and
loading games the results were very
impressive
the outer worlds which is a 45 gigabyte
game took about 2 minutes and 54 seconds
to
transfer onto the external ssd and 2
minutes and 5 seconds to transfer back
to the internal drive
when loading into the same save we used
for our previous tests it only took 13
seconds off the external ssd
which is very close to the internal
drive that took 11 seconds to load
for final fantasy 15 and 84 gigabyte
file it took 5 minutes and 50 seconds to
transfer onto the external ssd
and just 3 minutes and 56 seconds to
move back to the internal storage
and the load time results were great as
well just taking 15 seconds compared to
the 13 seconds of the internal drive
both final fantasy xv and the outer
worlds are xbox one games without series
x optimizations
so the results between the internal and
external ssds are due to the fact that
the games are simply working with the
raw speeds of those drives
there are other external ssds out there
but the samsung t5 in particular
usually goes for around 110 bucks for
500 gigabytes and 140 bucks for one
terabyte now moving on to a traditional
hard drive as i said earlier i use the
western digital passport with a usb
3.0 cable and things start to slow down
but it's not all that bad
to transfer the outer worlds from
internal storage onto the external hard
drive it took longer about 7 minutes and
35 seconds
and transferring back to the internal
drive took 7 minutes however in-game
load times remain decent
taking 26 seconds to load up the same
save we used previously with final
fantasy xv the transfer speeds took
longer as well
coming in at around 14 minutes and 24
seconds to move the game to the hard
drive and 12 minutes and 55 seconds to
get back onto internal storage
loading up save data remain reasonable
though taking 52 seconds for the same
save file we used before
it's no surprise that our hard drive is
going to be slower compared to an ssd
but these results aren't bad at all
and they're actually faster than current
gen consoles 2. the outer worlds took 43
seconds and final fantasy 15 took 1
minute and 11 seconds to load saves when
using the xbox one x
considering you get more space for
cheaper with a hard drive this would be
the cost effective route for bulk
storage or playing backwards compatible
games if you don't mind the slower load
times a western digital passport goes
for just 80 bucks for 2 terabytes and
110 bucks for a whopping 4 terabytes
so what's the best solution of course it
depends on what you want to get out of
your storage drives
for backwards compatible games an
external ssd would be ideal since you
still get quick load speeds
and transferring data is quite fast
which is ideal if you're frequently
moving series x specific games back and
forth
if cheaper mass storage is more of a
priority an external hard drive is the
way to go
load times for back and pack games are
still better than current gen systems
but you will miss out on those sweet ssd
speeds
transferring data takes considerably
longer but the importance between 6
minutes and 14 minutes to move an 85
gigabyte file well that's up to you
that one terabytes you get expansion
card sure is nice and 220 bucks
is fair if compared to other nvme ssds
for pc but that's still pretty steep
when looking at other solutions for the
series x
and s if you have any more questions
please drop them in the comments below
or hit me up on twitter at michaelp hyam
or if you want to see other games tested
let me know and don't forget to check
out my full xbox series x preview
and our weekly show gen next thanks for
watching and i'll see you all next time
you